hey it's cry like good old times its
salad ass like good old times
good I am really bloated what are you I
don't know I think I'm allergic to
something baby I mean like I'll say oh
you can switch it yeah how do you do
that I gonna press the Y button on your
controller okay it's positive time baby
it's the time all right so you go first
okay wait hang on who's going alright
there we go and now now you come over no
no there you go oh my god puzzles
I'm tip back ah well um hey oh oh [ __ ]
no no that's a good [ __ ] my main are you
go first
Thanks oh hey hey okay
oh say big Oh got alright alright okay
Oh
pull me up bro I can't pull me up breath
I actively can't
Oh Oh jump on my head are you serious
yes Josh are you oh yeah
oh my come on uh-huh yeah good good yeah
yeah done jump on me bro I'm coming to
help thank you oh good job
um this is awkward oh it's right there
how the [ __ ] did we get it from there I
think we gotta get up there first then
jump back around oh I know I know come
here okay alright that's gonna be tricky
this is gonna this is gonna work like
this I don't be down here you jump on me
and then you guys switch how what is I
think without the [ __ ] is wrong with you
enjoy no no no wait wait little man what
are you doing little guy what what are
you doing down I'm not very smart
alright come come back I'm gonna be
bouncing in your head okay alright you
ready my god
Oh Mike downs on my head you're way more
room at the same time okay okay one two
move don't you move
okay try Oh what why did you move I move
we're gonna get that coke bottle okay
I'm I'm gonna be all right right yes I
think okay I'm gonna move a little bit
huh oh my god okay keep moving just a
little bit each time
Oh God okay
all right we're doing it I like that you
pound me breath doing it good yes yes
okay all right it's gonna be risky oh oh
oh oh okay oh I don't work out so hot
hey man um I'm stuck okay Indiana Jones
that game come on okay we argue this
thing got it nice hey can I close this
Oh God
ha ha okay let's not do that it's not
let's not cut the umbilical cord try to
help you
thanks man it's it's not worried
employee I mean I appreciate the effort
uh watch it uh-huh you have any calories
and burning right now you're burning a
lot of calories right now we got to get
the chocolate at coca-cola we're not
leaving here without it okay okay uh
I'll come okay stay here States okay
I'll stay here Jake okay go you have one
chance do not miss a chance to blow this
opportunity comes once in a lifetime go
okay I'll jump on you you don't know how
to jam that personal attack it's not
you're strong as a spec man but you got
it all right spin all right I'll be
right here oh no come on
let me let me bounce it bounce
now this it's not your strongest week
Ignace I'm Anna and that is I know okay
okay now okay this happened oh I wanted
to happen okay I don't know how it's
gonna happen but hey your Hania okay now
no no no huh yeah up here yes I got away
miss gems I gotta say you got one shot
yeah coca-cola sponsored by coca-cola
get your coca-cola day at your nearest
Walker use my affiliate link in the
description cuz otherwise I don't get
paid thank you very much get the coke
hole with a add the code Cohen clues cry
let's cook yep yep puke and coke beauty
computer poker Cole Pole hmm
thank you so much for watching go check
out cry for you enjoy it and be free and
live your life how dare you advertise me
to your people and brofist protein oh
god it's gonna gonna kill us all I must
stop it
no no stop it rock